I am animals be a thing yes man
so who after the exhausting drama of the
Republican and Democratic conventions
the nightly show went on break last
weekend so it seems did Donald Trump's
goddamn mind I mean the man packed so
much crazy into one week that our show
tonight will be four hours um someone
tell Hardwick we're going wrong baby so
let's get started time for the
unblocking
all right so nice the nice compact
version it is very so Trump started his
week by criticizing the Muslim family of
a u.s. war hero he then doubled down on
his insults and he then KFC doubled down
on his inside seriously guys eating KFC
with the knife and fork is no way to
honor fallen American Colonel said I
said it I said it okay hey thank you and
Anna's offensive comments and petty
tweets about the Khan family didn't show
enough disrespect for our military just
look what happened on Tuesday when he
got this fun new gadget during a rally
in Virginia yesterday Trump said that he
was handed a Purple Heart from a retired
officer who supported him I said man
that's like that's like big stuff I
always wanted to get the Purple Heart
this was much easier this was much
easier Donald a Purple Heart is the
highest honor bestowed to those who were
wounded or killed when serving our
country it isn't some toy prize you're
getting a McDonald's Happy Meal nor nor
is it the literal Purple Heart of
beloved McDonald's character grimace
right
still after stealing this Purple Heart
the gops Hamburglar went after one of
our nation's most famous Purple Heart
recipients you know never been a big fan
of John McCain and I I just hate the way
our veterans have been treated by John
and other people okay
he thinks five and a half years of POWs
John McCain is the person disrespecting
veterans right now you know what I've
run out of words to call this fool an
idiot or to call this idiot a fool I
can't you know here you go to help me
out guys we have a couple of US veterans
on our staff here for a new segment
veterans who worth of the nightly show
respond to Donald Trump's disrespecting
the military because Larry's run out of
words
by the way guys thank you for your
service by the way and I wonder if you
can help me up I'm just one word
no problem Larry we got this it is with
honor that we bestowed this special
commendation upon Donald Trump
thanks guys Ventura Fulton have done
anything to get to everybody corks last
week Donald Trump's grudge against John
McCain led him to hold his endorsement
for the Arizona senator as well as Paul
Ryan but after getting a stern
talking-to from RNC detention room
monitor Reince Priebus
Trump came around I support and endorse
our Speaker of the House Paul Ryan and
while I'm at it I hold in the highest
esteem Senator John McCain honey I love
you we we will be together forever wife
I think it's hard to tell when he seems
the most crazy when he's reading from a
script' when he goes off of it alright
here he is expertly displaying his non
grasp of foreign policy and geography
when asked about Putin he's not going
into Ukraine okay just so you understand
he's not gonna go into Ukraine all right
you can mark it down you can put it down
you can take it anyway sorry there isn't
okay well he's there in a certain way
but I'm not there yet you're not there
yet
where is there a basic level of
intelligence and awareness of the world
you know you don't need security
clearance to know they just need the
newspaper and not even a good one
that's right but you could you can stay
in a Days Inn and deduce it from the
pictures in the USA Today come on come
on alright guys so after an historically
awful week Donald Trump has dropped
precipitously in the post and his media
surrogates have a lot to explain but
they always managed to avoid actually
explaining anything this is not what we
should be talking about right now Victor
we should we talk about Hillary contact
the issue is not mr. Cohn and Donald
Trump the issue really is you know
radical jihad radical Islamic Jihad do
you believe this election could be
rigged I think what he's talking about
is the very unfair media coverage that
Republicans get see this is what happens
when you drink the Trump kool-aid it no
it's true it's like if you're in the
position of having to defend Jeffrey
Dahmer right it's like okay did Jeffrey
Dahmer
eat those people you're asking me if
it's fair to judge people based on an
eating disorder I don't think you want
me to answer that
in other words Trump surrogates your
candidate is a cannibal and should not
be in charge of running the country all
right so to help us unpack this as
Trump's chief media strategist an on-air
communications coordinator Stephanie
Spencer
so Stephanie let me ask you a very
direct question why isn't Trump better
informed on foreign policy if what
you're asking me is why the Clinton
Obama foreign policy is so horrible I
think the American people want an answer
to that okay okay see no no no so you
just did it see that wasn't what I was
asking you you just change the question
I'm not gonna let you get away with this
just answer this simple question why
isn't Trump better informed on foreign
policy just so we're on the same page
your question to me is go ahead
why isn't yes crooked Hillary Clinton
answering questions of matter emails I
agree with Bernie Sanders we need to
know more about her Damn emails no you
didn't hear that right I think you just
refused to answer anything ever November
what well you just asked when will
Donald Trump win this election in a
historic landslide
I didn't just ask that I never said that
that's not even close to what I think
what happened in Benghazi was a tragedy
and Hillary Clinton still has not
answered for it I never said that this
is so frustrating
oh let me try this your candidate is
such an enormous Lea undisciplined
show you can't even engage in simple
human back-and-forth communication
because to do so would probably lead to
you having to admit that there's
absolutely no reason anyone should vote
for Donald I on this Larry wait you
actually agree with me yes just like you
said Donald Trump he's the only
candidate and that's the newts race who
will make America great again I never
said this
Stephanie Spencer everyone we'll be
right back you can
you